upper Moon 5 gyoko is a creepy porcelain
vase making Maniac who has a taste for
human children and an obsession with
pleasing muzon gyoko's blood demon art
is centered around porcelain vases and
around water and sea creatures he can
create multiple vases of different sizes
and distribute them all around him he is
then able to teleport from one vase to
another which makes him incredibly
difficult to pin down in battle he can
also trap his opponents inside these
vases and then drown them in water or do
some other sick thing that he had
planned for them gyoko can also create
fish monsters of various shapes and
sizes and launch them at his opponents
he can summon giant octopus tentacles
from his vases and use them to attack or
restrain his enemies and more for more
information on gyoko including his
backstory and final form check out my
full video link in the description and
in the pinned comment